welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your house definition and this episode
we are going on the serac attack as we
break down why the big villain in wess
world will lose Ciroc has quickly become
a fascinating figure but the more time
that we've spent with him the more we've
learned he has one humongous floor
throughout this video we're going to be
breaking down what that is and why it
will ultimately lead to his undoing
obviously false spoilers here for
Westworld season 3 so if you haven't
watched up to episode 6 yet then you
need to disappear faster than serac when
someone thinks they've killed him make
sure you subscribe to the channel but
breakdowns like this every day and
please smash the thumbs up button like
sir axe smash Dempsey's head in if you
enjoy the video I'll stop with the Ciroc
jokes now anyway thank you for clicking
this now let's get into our breakdown of
why we thinks Iraq will ultimately lose
okay so Soraka is a pretty mysterious
figure that feels like he's an enigma
wrapped within a mystery wrapped within
a hologram there's very little that we
actually know about him but throughout
the series we have learned tiny tidbits
of information about his past before we
get into his massive flaw we have to
discuss his backstory as this all kind
of ties into who he is and why he's
developed this lodge weakness firstly
anger and Ciroc which Homer pronounced
right don't kill me spent most of his
childhood in Paris with his brother shun
me during the annihilation of the city
the two are playing on the outskirts of
the location and thus they avoided the
nuke that was dropped upon it this they
massively shaped the character and it
was during this that he realized the
true enemy of humanity was humanity
itself was created out of greed in
despair hate and Prejudice and this
started him and his brother off in the
path of creating a means to save the
human race from itself together they
created Rehoboam a machine that took all
of the data on humanity collected before
privacy laws came into place and then
predicted the path that our species
would take using this data it created an
algorithm that would put each person on
the planet on a path that would make the
species elevate as a whole it was able
to successfully predict the stock market
and the pair's business partner Liam
dancey senior was blown away by this in
the end it allowed the sax
dempsey to a massive fortune however the
machine's predictions always had a snack
a problem once they reached a certain
point that showed humanity was doomed
Rehoboam had identified anomalies
outliers that it was unable to predict
and serac view these as problems thus he
started to abduct them he placed them
into reeducation centers that will
completely change their memories and
even went so far as putting his brother
into one to serac stay that this is
because he planned on killing dempsey
senior and thus he had to be removed
from society however in a shocking twist
serac himself killed the business mogul
and covered his death up with a plane
crash this is because Liam threatened to
expose surak's experiments and since
then serac has ruled the world from the
shadows and slowly he has become the
richest man on earth he has used his
knowledge of Rehoboam to wipe out all
trace of his existence and he silently
works away saving the human race from
itself
we album correctly predicted that the
host would start an uprising in West
world and it also successfully guessed
just how much of a problem that Dolores
would be and identified flaws within
Delos namely Charlotte Hale and games to
Rack strategies on how to acquire the
company through its stocks and shares
overall serac and his machine seemed
invincible and that's exactly why
they're so flawed serac thinks the
machine is a god now sir axe biggest
problem is that he believes Rehoboam is
always right and that is his blind spot
though it has correctly predicted a lot
of things that doesn't mean it's right
all the time now this kind of ties back
into the mirror world theory in some
ways and we'll just kind of be
discussing how it does make mistakes in
episode three Dolores told Caleb that
Rehoboam had created a mirror world in
which it runs a simulation that shows
how events will play out and it uses
these to predict the future now we have
already theorized that we were given a
hint of this with Charlotte Hale Loras
who in the very same episode watched
back a message that the original Hale
left for a son upon believing that she
would die she watched it two times and
yeah you have to pay close attention to
this as the raw ever-so-slight dialog
changes in both messages
you wanted me to sing you a song
Kentucky went missing you our song the
night that I left you wanted me to tuck
you in just gives home or so
[Music]
okay so they're probably 90% the same
but they do differ in subtle ways that
indicate they're both different messages
and thus it is possible that theorize
that one is in the mirror world
simulation whilst the other isn't what
this hints at is that Rehoboam gets a
lot of things right but I can still get
things wrong this was made more evident
in Episode six
when serac identified hale as a host by
stating that the real one would never
take time to check in on a son I think
this is wrong and clearly from the
message that she left in what could have
been her death she did care for him deep
down I think that in the face of the
world collapsing she would have checked
in on him too but serac believes that
his machine completely understands
humanity and therefore it doesn't get
things wrong so he incorrectly assumes
that Hale would never check in on her
son and though he does house - hey loris
it does play his hand and shows he puts
too much faith in it when it can be
incorrect now I don't know if you've
seen devs or not so I won't spoil too
much of it but basically in that a CEO
of a tech company has created a similar
machine to Rehoboam that seemingly can
predict the future he believes it to be
a God that is always right and the show
asks whether we actually have free will
or not in that he resigns himself to the
fact that he doesn't
thus he can't make choices and I believe
that this is carried across with Ciroc
to some extent as he thinks the machine
is flawless we've already seen firsthand
that Rehoboam can be wrong as it
shouldn't join me for wishing to kill
dempsey senior yet
let's serac do it anyway or or it didn't
and he exercised the choice serac
himself realized he needed to take
Dempsey senior out and he disobeyed the
machine showing that it can be wrong or
the machine told him to do it and it
provided a contradictory strategy I'm
leaning more towards to the former as
Dempsey said he knew he would be fine at
the meeting but it does show that there
are flaws within it and deep down to
Rack knows this too as a whole though
serac still puts all his faith firmly
into Rehoboam still knowing that
sometimes humanity must make its own
choices and yet he dooms the rest of us
to follow in its plan now I may be way
off with this next part
but I do you think that the evidence is
there actually believe that Rehoboam
isn't necessarily a full prediction
algorithm and instead I think all that
it does is identify people who may be
problems in order to keep the world safe
sure it runs scenarios but as we've
already shown these can be wrong
instead all Rehoboam really does is
avert the world from war by identifying
people that are unpredictable and then
serac takes these people we educates
them and puts them back into society all
it's basically doing is well I'll
imagine you got on a train home one
night and there was a gang there there
is a chance that they could mug you but
there's also a chance that they won't
and there just leave you alone now being
in that situation I'm sure most people
would just want to avoid the chance of
being mugged and if they could take the
gang out of the equation even though
there is potential there that they won't
actually do it
that is how robbing works on a grand
scale serac is traumatized by the
childhood tragedy that he encountered
and he's basically removing all
possibility of the world going to war by
getting rid of anyone that could be a
problem now a lot of these people would
probably go on to be fine and not cause
anything bad to happen but they can't be
predicted and serac doesn't want to take
that chance
his biggest flaw is that he doesn't let
humanity live up to its full potential
instead people are given roles and
forced into them when companies are
hiring they're given data by Rehoboam
and they don't hire anyone that looks
like they may be a problem and thus
people like Caleb are forced to stay
stuck in their loops so rack does not
believe that anyone can strive beyond
the position that Rehoboam is picked for
them however if it's one thing that
we've learned from Westworld time and
time again it's that the people or hosts
often can I think this is why upon
learning their path so many people threw
off the handle they knew that they could
be more than what the Machine had
predicted them to be but they're not
gonna get the opportunity we often hear
a rags-to-riches stories and
billionaires that came from nothing
imagine if four ho bum had him looked at
Jeff Bezos feature I mean here is a guy
who was the son of a 17 year old high
school student and a bike shop owner a
dower would have predicted him as the
real world serac and he'd probably still
be stuck working minimum wage in a
bookstore serac puts his
complete trust in the machine but it's
probably not that good at even
predicting stuff we can't see humanity
for its full potential actually believe
that the reason it can't predict beyond
a certain point isn't because the world
it's ending I just don't think I'm the
machine is actually that good at seeing
beyond a certain point up the fraction
of data that it owns it's basically a
piece of crap when I think about it and
yet serac trusts it fully to the point
he would even jail his own brother is
one connection to his past he's
basically Batman at this point mega rich
man that had a tragic event happen in
front of his eyes when he was a child
and he's forced the world to fit into a
certain way in order to avoid chaos
serac is a rich man who has denied
people of their choices and therefore it
welcome back and bites him the rich have
long been a common enemy in West's world
and I think that arrogance will
ultimately be their downfall
this is apparent in the death of Liam
Dempsey Jr who is killed by ash just
before this happens he brights the group
and says they don't have a choice
that shoots him and says guess I do have
a choice I can't do the voice this shows
that people can ultimately rise above
all things and when they are given
choices that they can take down the
people in power people can go beyond
what has been planned for them and this
is very apparent here even leading to
the death of Dempsey jr. who didn't see
it coming at all similar to how I thinks
Iraq will perish so in summary we must
not put our faith in false prophets
because they can ultimately lead us down
the wrong path and allow us to be
completely blindsided surak's biggest
flaw is that he doesn't see humanity for
what it can truly be and therefore he
will be brought down because of it
and that's the video obviously I loved
hear your thoughts on serac so comment
below and let me know if you enjoyed
this then please hit the thumbs up
button as it massively helps us out and
don't forget to check out our breakdown
of episode 6 which is gonna be linked at
the end we're going through the season
week by week and pointing out the things
you missed as well as giving our
predictions so it's definitely worth
checking out after this every month on
the 15th we give away free blu-rays and
all you have to do to be in with a
chance of winning the Marvel phase three
part one box set is leave a like and
subscribe with notifications on you want
to support the channel and get to see
content early then please consider
clicking the join button below
you can also come chat to us on a
discord server link below or a
definition whitey on Twitter thanks for
making it till the end of the video
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
but the beasts
[Music]
you